vean a este tenis que tenemos aquí vamos
a usar este tenis para ilustrar algunos
problemas un poquito más complicados
sobre la fuerza normal una idea errónea
es que las personas se olvidan de que la
fuerza normal es una fuerza de contacto
solo tendremos la fuerza normal cuando
dos superficies estén en contacto cuando
el tenis está en contacto con el piso
tendremos una fuerza normal en el tenis
y otra fuerza normal en el piso o si el
tema se estuviera en contacto con la
pared habría una fuerza normal en la
pared y una fuerza normal en el tenis
pero si el tenis estuviera flotando en
el aire y esto es lo que muchas personas
piensan imagínense que este tenis está
cayendo y el problema les pide que
calculen las fuerzas que están actuando
en el zapato mientras está cayendo las
personas están tan acostumbradas a tener
en cuenta la fuerza normal que cometen
este error y dicen bueno tenemos nuestra
fuerza de gravedad esto está bien
en la tierra y cercana a la tierra
siempre vamos a tener la fuerza de
gravedad esta fuerza nos va a jalar
hacia abajo con una fuerza m por g pero
están tan acostumbrados a tener la
fuerza normal es decir la fuerza normal
aparecen muchísimos problemas de física
tanto que a veces se hace como un
reflejo y las personas automáticamente
incluyen la fuerza normal por lo que
dicen bueno pues tiene que haber una
fuerza normal siempre hay una fuerza
normal pero no siempre hay una fuerza
normal si el zapato no está en contacto
con superficie alguna no tendremos
fuerza normal no será hasta que el
zapato toque el suelo o toque otra
superficie que tendremos nuestra fuerza
normal si ponemos el zapato aquí y lo
dejamos descansar sobre el suelo aquí sí
tendremos una fuerza normal la fuerza
normal va a apuntar hacia arriba y esto
es lo que las personas dicen que se
cumple y si se cumple pero solamente
cuando tenemos dos superficies que se
están tocando pero si no están en
contacto no tendremos fuerza normal
hay otra idea errónea muchos piensan que
la fuerza normal siempre va a ser igual
a m porque porque nuevamente en muchos
problemas esta fuerza normal siempre es
igual a m por g por lo que muchos
piensen que siempre se va a cumplir esto
se vuelve una reacción que las personas
vean la fuerza normal y automáticamente
quieren poner m por g y esto sería
cierto en un caso sencillo pero les voy
a mostrar a continuación cuando esto no
se cumple y qué hacer si esto no se
cumple por ejemplo cuáles será la fuerza
normal en estos zapatos suponemos que el
zapato tiene una masa de m cuál será la
fuerza normal pues podemos usar la
segunda ley de newton y siempre usamos
la segunda ley de newton que nos dice
que la aceleración es igual a la fuerza
neta dividida entre la masa
en este caso ya que tenemos fuerzas
verticales voy a considerar la
aceleración en la dirección vertical así
que será la fuerza neta en la dirección
vertical cuál sería la aceleración de
este zapato verticalmente si estuviera
quieto en esta superficie sin que se
mueva o cambie su velocidad pues la
aceleración va a ser cero la aceleración
vertical es cero para la fuerza neta
tengo una fuerza normal hacia arriba
'queremos positiva si ésta fn representa
la magnitud de la fuerza normal
ésta es una fuerza positiva y es lo que
indicó aquí con este + todas las fuerzas
hacia arriba las vamos a considerar
positivas y esta fuerza gravitacional
que es hacia abajo va a ser negativa y
si m porque representa el tamaño de la
fuerza gravitacional pongo aquí un menos
para representar que la dirección es
hacia abajo
y divido todo entre la masa del zapato y
si hago esto me voy a encontrar que
estas dos fuerzas divididas entre la
masa van a ser cero de acuerdo a la
segunda ley de newton
pero multiplico ambos lados de la
ecuación por la masa cuando hago esto el
lado izquierdo sigue siendo cero y me
queda que esto es igual a la fuerza
normal menos m por g
y si despejo la fuerza normal tendré que
la fuerza normal va a igualar a la
fuerza de gravedad m por g y mucha gente
me dirá bueno pues obvio esto ya lo
sabía la fuerza normal siempre es igual
a m por g pero no esto no siempre es así
solo es igual a m por g en este caso
porque sólo teníamos estas dos fuerzas
vean nuestras suposiciones aquí sólo
tenemos la fuerza normal y la fuerza de
gravedad y supusimos que la aceleración
es de cero si cambiamos alguno de estos
requisitos la fuerza normal ya no va a
ser igual a m por g y aquí tenemos una
superficie horizontal en donde está
descansando el zapato ese es otro
requisito nuevamente aquí no tenemos una
razón para considerar esto en la
dirección vertical también podríamos
tener una fuerza normal en la dirección
horizontal así que vamos a tratar de
cambiar estos requisitos de uno en uno
y veremos qué hace esto o cómo afecta a
la fuerza normal en otras palabras qué
pasaría si yo agrego otra fuerza
digamos que dejamos el zapato en el
suelo pero lo empujamos hacia abajo y
digamos que lo estoy empujando hacia
abajo con una fuerza que llamamos f1 una
fuerza con magnitud de f1 que va en la
dirección hacia abajo esto como me va a
afectar mi problema pues va a ser un
poquito más difícil lo que hacemos es
que la aceleración sigue siendo cero
digamos que esto sigue aquí no tenemos
que hacer nada con el lado izquierdo
sigue siendo cero pero ahora en esta
fuerza de aquí voy a tener esta fuerza
f1 que apunta hacia abajo por lo que me
diagrama de fuerzas tendrá otra fuerza
que apunta hacia abajo
efe uno negativo ya que va en la
dirección hacia abajo y cuando despejó
fn sumo m porque en ambos lados para
cancelar esto y tengo que sumar f1 en
ambos lados para cancelar esta f1
negativa
y me queda m por g más f1 por lo que
tendremos que nuestra fuerza normal va a
ser mayor en una cantidad f 1 lo que
tiene sentido ya que si empujó hacia
abajo con una fuerza extra no sé de diez
newtons va a haber más presión por lo
que tiene sentido que la presión entre
el zapato y el suelo aumente estamos
apretando estas dos superficies con una
fuerza mayor por lo que el suelo tiene
que empujar hacia arriba con una fuerza
mayor para mantener este objeto fuera de
la superficie eso es lo que hace la
fuerza normal evita que el objeto evita
que el objeto pase a través de la
superficie así que si aplastó un objeto
en una superficie su fuerza normal va a
aumentar y aumentar justamente la
cantidad que estamos apretando ahora
digamos que tenemos una fuerza hacia
arriba
alguien está jalando el zapato hacia
arriba mientras nosotros lo estamos
jalando hacia abajo nos estamos peleando
por el zapato ya que se dan cuenta que
es un tenis muy padre y todo mundo lo
quiere tenemos una f2 que apunta hacia
arriba
ahora tenemos otra fuerza en nuestro
diagrama una que apunta hacia arriba a
esta le llamamos efe 2 y ahora cómo va a
cambiar esto nuestra aceleración sigue
siendo 0 pero ahora tengo una fuerza
hacia arriba tenemos que agregar
efe 2 positivo porque es una fuerza
vertical que va en dirección hacia
arriba y aquí cuando despejó esto sume m
por g en ambos lados sume f1 también en
ambos lados pero ahora tengo que restar
efe 2 en ambos lados así que ahora tengo
que la fuerza normal es igual a m por g
+ efe 1 - efe 2 y eso tiene sentido si
estoy jalando hacia arriba un zapato a
relajar la presión entre el zapato y la
superficie
si yo jaló hacia arriba con 20 newtons
puede reducir la fuerza normal en esta
cantidad ya que estoy aliviando esta
presión entre el zapato y el suelo vamos
a hacerlo un poco más difícil ya que a
veces nos encontramos unos problemas
bien extraños que no sabemos cómo
resolver
digamos que tenemos otra fuerza y esta
fuerza va a ser una fuerza diagonal voy
a jalar de este lado esto va a tener un
ángulo y bueno eso se pone interesante
digamos que esto es f 3 f 3 va a estar
jalando con un ángulo que le vamos a
llamar fin el ángulo que forma esta
fuerza con la horizontal y ahora que
hacemos tenemos este ángulo extraño aquí
y ahora f 3 va a estar jalando hacia acá
agregó otra fuerza mi diagrama de
fuerzas y tengo que encontrar cómo voy a
incluir esto en mi fuerza neta vertical
para incluirla aquí en mi segunda ley de
newton vertical
no puedo instruir la magnitud completa
de f3 y ese es otro error que muchas
personas cometen que quieren sumar o
restar f3 completo esto no lo podemos
hacer porque esta fórmula es la versión
vertical de la segunda ley de newton
o lo aplica a las fuerzas que tienen
dirección vertical pero f3 está
apuntando tanto vertical como
horizontalmente así que sólo tengo que
incluir el componente vertical de f3 lo
que tengo que decir es que esta f3 va a
tener un componente vertical ese
componente vertical lo voy a llamar f 3
y indicando que es f 13 en la dirección
vertical y también tendrá un componente
horizontal
que le llamamos f 3x que es f 3 en la
dirección horizontal si quiero despejar
efe 3 tendrá que usar la definición del
seno y sé que es el seno porque este
lado es el opuesto al ángulo y sé que el
seno relaciona el lado opuesto con la
hipotenusa así que escribo esto como el
seno de fin que es igual al lado opuesto
efe 3 y dividido entre el total de f3
que es mi hipotenusa si despejó de aquí
efe 3 y me queda que f 3 en la dirección
y va a ser igual a efe 3 por el seno del
ángulo fi y ahora puedo incluir esto en
mi fuerza neta esto apunta hacia arriba
por lo que este componente vertical va a
agregarse de forma positiva más
efe tres seno de fi
y cuando restamos f3 seno de fi en ambos
lados aquí me va a quedar menos f de 3
seno de fi lo que tiene sentido ya que
si estamos jalando hacia arriba sabemos
que vamos a reducir algo de la presión
entre el zapato y la superficie por lo
que se reduce la fuerza normal y es por
eso que restamos este f3 seno de fi y
otra manera de llevar este problema al
siguiente nivel sería decir que este
cuarto no es un cuarto quizás es un
elevador y este elevador se está
acelerando hacia arriba con una
aceleración a cero y en este caso nada
va a cambiar del lado derecho de la
ecuación muchos piensan que si hay
aceleración esto me va a afectar como si
fuera una nueva fuerza
estas son las únicas fuerzas lo que me
va a afectar es que en lugar de tener el
cero
voy a tener aquí la aceleración que
corresponde en este caso sería a cero o
la aceleración que corresponde y este es
el único cambio podemos igual despejar
efe n de la misma manera y aquí cuando
multiplicamos por m no va a ser cero
vamos a tener m por a cero y aquí
tendremos un más a cero por m cuando les
dejemos nuestra fuerza normal y creo que
con esto hemos visto todas las opciones
posibles con el ejemplo del zapato en el
suelo creo que es bastante más complejo
de los ejemplos que podrían encontrarse
pero ahora ya saben cómo tratar
cualquier tipo de fuerza que actúe aquí
o cualquier aceleración